[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend die omikron variante des
corona virus hat offenbar fuß gefasst in
europa noch sind die fallzahlen gering
aber das kann sich schnell ändern die
gewohnten chor oder zahlen haben sich
heute mal nicht so groß verändert aber
das heißt an einem wochenende nicht arg
viel was sich rapide verändert ist das
bewusstsein der öffentlichkeit die die
lage erkennbar immer ernster nimmt man
spürt das und es ist messbar eine
deutliche mehrheit findet im aktuellen
politbarometer es werde nicht genug zum
schutz gegen korona getan und das macht
schon auch eindruck wenn die nationale
akademie der wissenschaften in einem
gemeinsamen brandbrief führender
fachleute
sofort entschiedenes handeln verlangt
und die nachrichten dann abends melden
müssen dass nichts entschieden wurde
nicht mal ein eiliger termin für eine
entscheidung
christina kajaks berichtet die aktuelle
lage und dann gibt es fragen an
professor christian rost
es ist ein ungewöhnlicher
adventsgottesdienst heute in der
dresdner frauenkirche im angesicht
steigender infektionszahlen hatte sich
die sächsische landeskirche entschlossen
nicht nur zu predigen und zu beten
sondern auch ein impfangebot zu machen
viele gläubige fanden das offenbar gut
schon nach anderthalb stunden waren die
online tickets weg im großteil sind es
auffrischungsimpfung aber gott sei dank
haben wir auch erst im klinge die er
sich bereit erklären weil es einfach
eine niedrige schwelle ist
der pfarrer vermag einen zusammenhang zu
erkennen zwischen der christlichen
advents botschaft und dem impfen in
zeiten der pandemie advent heißt ja es
ist eine zeit in der in viel dunkelheit
immer mehr lichter angezündet werden und
das ist es immer besser wenn man das
kleinste licht anzündet schallt über die
allgemeine dunkelheit zu klagen und ich
denke mit dieser impfaktion tun wir
genau das mit zünden lichter an auf dem
weg der nach meinung aller fachleute
derjenige ist der als einziger wirklich
ein weg aus dieser pandemie herr
ausweisen kann
vorerst aber steigen die
infektionszahlen und die neue omikron
variante breitet sich weiter aus heute
die bestätigung dass auch ein hessischer
reisen daraus südafrika die
virusvariante mitgebracht hat wie
gefährlich sie ist weiß bislang niemand
genau davon ausgehen dass die impfstoffe
nicht perfekt wirken somit ist das also
sehr besorgniserregend in der summe
wahrscheinlich ansteckender
wahrscheinlich auch etwas also
schwieriger für die geimpften und ich
glaube nicht an einen leichteren verlauf
dabei nimmt die debatte über eine
impfpflicht fahrt auf bisher von den
ampel koalitionären abgelehnt wird sie
jetzt von niedersachsens
ministerpräsident weil in einem
zeitungsinterview gefordert erste
untersuchungen zeigen dass vor allem buß
der impfungen auch gegen diese mutation
eine gute wirkung entfalten können
deshalb ist spätestens jetzt eine
allgemeine impfpflicht unabdingbar wir
müssen den impf druck unbedingt erhöhen
die fdp reagierte skeptisch
ich möchte von verfassungsrechtlern
hören ob das möglich ist wie lange haben
die verfassungsrechtler ja gesagt das
ist nicht möglich wenn ja jetzt gibt es
jetzt gibt es eine einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht aber die allgemeine
impfpflicht über die wir gerne
debattieren können die wird zur vierten
werde jetzt nichts beitragen wie aber
umgehen mit der vierten welle und der
überlastung der intensivstationen wären
schwer kranke corona patienten durch
deutschland geflogen werden auf der
suche nach einem freien intensiv bett
wächst in der gesellschaft die
verunsicherung
weil die menschen halt brauchen es und
hier haben wir jetzt ganz merkwürdige
zweig zweig +3 die regelungen je nachdem
wir wissen gar nicht was eigentlich
geheilt heißt wie lange das zurücklegen
muss insofern klar und da können die
leute auch mit leben das wissen wir die
akzeptanz diesbezüglich ist hoch mit 70
80 prozent wir sollten klarheit schaffen
flächendeckend klarheit schaffen in
einer diffusen lage eine große aufgabe
der sich die neue regierung widmen muss
ganz am anfang der pandemie hat das team
von professor draußen an der berliner
charité den ersten zuverlässigen test
pcr test entwickelt der die krankheit
nachwies er kennt die codes des virus
guten abend nach berlin guten abend herr
kleber ich weiß wir wissen noch nicht so
arg viel aber nach allem was berichtet
wird auch von fachkollegen und nach den
hinweisen sie sie bekommen kann diese
omikron variante die sache nochmal
deutlich schlimmer machen ja leider also
wir wissen tatsächlich nicht allzu viel
darüber ich bin schon ziemlich besorgt
im moment muss ich sagen ich bin
überrascht so viele mutationen in diesem
virus zu sehen das ist dann allerdings
auch das einzige was wirklich greifbar
ist diese mutationen und man versteht
nicht immer gleich was mutationen dann
im echten leben machen es gibt ja heute
in den medien berichte über milde
verläufe ich finde daran ist noch nicht
sehr viel substanz wir haben gerade mal
etwas über 1000 fälle überhaupt
nachgewiesen und deren klinischen
verlauf muss man erst mal sehen
das heißt man muss da wirklich für alles
offen sein was man schon sagen kann ist
dass diese infektion hier sehr häufig
bei jungen leuten auftritt in südafrika
bei leuten die in aller erster linie
dieser erkrankung auch schon hinter sich
haben das jetzt als zweite oder sogar
dritte infektion bekommen und dann eben
auch wieder mit symptomen keiner kann im
moment sagen was da auf uns zukommt das
einzige was man glaube ich wirklich mit
sicherheit sagen kann ist
es ist besser wenn man geimpft ist es
ist noch besser wenn man gewusst hat ist
nun ist es ja so dass jemand der bisher
als genesen gilt schon als ähnlich oder
vielleicht sogar besser geschützt als
durch die impfung galt wenn sie jetzt
sagen in südafrika erkranken menschen
die schon richtig cupid hatten dann
spricht das dafür dass jedenfalls dieser
schutz unterlaufen werden könnte das ist
genau die sorge dass wir hier eben jetzt
eine erste wirkliche immun escape also
immun flucht mutante vor uns haben die
anderen mutanten bisher hatten diese
eigenschaft noch nicht so stark und
alle sind natürlich da auch ein bisschen
nervös und gespannt ob man
möglicherweise so viel schutz verliert
sowohl durch die überstandenen infektion
wie hoffentlich nicht durch die
impfungen dass man sogar die impfungen
noch mal verändern müsste alles das
werden sicherlich die nächsten zwei bis
drei wochen beantworten wir müssen auch
verstehen wie es jetzt wirklich mit der
krankheit schwere ist und was wir im
moment noch gar nicht sagen können ist
wie sich das bei uns verhält denn hier
hat das virus andere bedingungen als in
südafrika bei uns sind viele menschen
geimpft eben nicht genesen und das ist
ein unterschied
und in unserer bevölkerung müssen wir
eben auch ganz genau hinschauen und muss
auch sagen es gibt eben schon immer mehr
meldungen die ich so rein bekomme aus
dem kollegen kollegenkreis dass es doch
schon einiges an infektionen gibt in
deutschland und in europa das klingt
doch ein bisschen anders als die ersten
stellungnahmen von fachleuten gestern
allerdings haben die ja auch immer dazu
gesagt wir können noch ganz wenig sagen
aber ich spüre jetzt ein bisschen andere
tonalität in ihrer auskunft genau also
es ist tatsächlich eine situation die
sich von tag zu tag weiter entwickelt
und momentan wissen wir nicht was da auf
uns zukommt
es fühlt sich aber anders an als die
ersten informationen bei der alpha und
der delta variante darum finde ich wir
sollten das jetzt lieber ernst nehmen
wenn sich dann doch zeigen sollte dass
hier beispielsweise die symptome schwere
abgemildert ist dann können wir alle
ziemlich erleichtert sein aber ich bin
da sehr weit im moment davon weg von
dieser auffassung wird man denn
zuverlässig darauf zu können dass es
gelingen wird die impfstoffe wieder
anzupassen das soll ja gerade der große
vorteil dieser modernen impf technik
sein dass man solche mutationen wieder
einfangen kann ja das ist richtig das
wird man technisch relativ einfach
machen können und auch regulativ ist
dieser weg vorgeformt aber wir sprechen
hier doch von monaten bis so von
mehreren monaten bis da die ersten dosen
wirklich ausgeliefert werden und dann
müssen ja wirklich größere zahlen
produziert werden das ist also gar nicht
dass akute aktuelle probleme wir müssen
jetzt mit den verfügbaren impfstoffen
die gegen den schweren verlauf mit
wirklich sehr sehr großer
wahrscheinlichkeit schützen werden egal
ob diese variante jetzt für die
übertragbarkeit
sagen wir mal besser zugänglich ist
wir müssen jetzt sehen dass wir zwei
dinge machen wir müssen boostern so
schnell es irgend geht denn unser
eigentliches problem ist ja weiter die
delta variante die winter welle die wir
jetzt haben dagegen ist also die omikron
variante die jetzt aus südafrika kommt
ein mini problem im moment und wir
müssen die impflücken schließen
unbedingt das ist ganz entscheidend denn
wenn man gar nicht geschützt ist möchte
man auch die omikron variante nicht
nicht treffen nun kommen wir mal auf das
aktuelle problem dass er ja auch ohne
omikron hätten die leopoldina die
nationale akademie der wissenschaften
hat unter ihrer beteiligung gestern ein
brandbrief geschrieben dass sofort was
passieren müsste der wahrscheinlich
nächste kanzler hat in den letzten tagen
gesagt nur warten wir doch mal ab wir
haben doch gerade eben verschärfungen
beschlossen 3g an den arbeitsplätzen
zweig in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
große appelle von allen seiten doch zur
impfung zu gehen und abstand zu halten
vielleicht greift das ja warum drängen
sie so auf 23 4 tage naja es ist im
moment ja besorgniserregend was man in
einigen bundesländern schon auf den
intensivstationen sieht ich glaube das
müssen wir jetzt hier nicht ausführen
das ist ja teil der berichterstattung
wir haben einfach eine etwas unwägbare
situation diese codes zu die 3g mit
denen hat man eigentlich keine erfahrung
bisher gemacht in einer wirklichen
winter welle wir haben hier ja eine
differenzierung geimpft versus ungeimpft
während wir aber genau so gar nicht
wissen wie denn die übertragung direkt
übertragung durch die geimpften ist das
muss man also alles annehmen und im
moment ist das eine situation wie kann
kaum noch jemand modellieren und
gleichzeitig sehen wir dass die
infektionszahlen doch relativ
unbeeindruckt sind von der ganzen sache
von diesen 2 oder 3 gs die man da
anwendet und ich glaube das ist das
wichtigste was man jetzt im moment auch
wirklich der politik empfehlen kann ganz
genau hinzuschauen den gebieten
beispielsweise österreich sachsen bayern
wo schon in verschärftem maße diese
maßnahmen jetzt angewandt werden wo also
großveranstaltungen schon abgesagt
werden und dann man sich eben auf dieses
klein management geben faces ungeimpft
wer darf an einer veranstaltung
teilnehmen wo man sich ja dass das aktiv
gemacht hat und wo man jetzt so langsam
anfangen kann effekte zu sehen also in
bayern beispielsweise geht der er wird
langsam ein bisschen runter gegen eins
wir müssen aber auf 0,7 kommen um
wirklich in absehbarer zeit die fallzahl
so runter zu bekommen dass eine
entspannung auf der intensivstation
möglich ist und da sind wir schon
ziemlich weit von entfernt nach sie
haben in diesem brief an die
verantwortlichen geschrieben ist müsste
sofort anfang nächster woche inzwischen
ist sonntag also ab morgen müsste
energisches passieren danach schießt es
zu dieser stunde jetzt aber nicht aus
was passiert denn wenn nichts passiert
außer dass man nach kräften die
impfungen hochfährt was ist dann die
zeit bis weihnachten was steht uns bevor
naja ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
verimpft der booster dosen schnell genug
gehen kann also in israel war die
erfahrung dass man die halbe bevölkerung
mit einem booster versorgt hatte und
dann gegen die inzidenz doch merklich
runter davon sind wir weit entfernt wir
haben ungefähr acht millionen gewusst
hat die hälfte unserer bevölkerung
werden über 40 millionen das ist also
bis weihnacht nicht zu schaffen und das
ist die große
sorge eigentlich dass wir dann eben das
reale problem bekommen in der
intensivmedizin dass wir einfach nicht
mehr die betten haben man könnte auch
ein paar positive nachrichten dazu geben
es ist tatsächlich im moment so dass wir
ein etwas absinken der krankheit schwere
sehen das heißt es müssen nicht mehr wie
noch vor ein paar monaten so ein prozent
der infizierten beatmet werden sondern
das geht jetzt so auf 0,7 prozent 0,6
prozent vielleicht und weiter sinkend
kommt sicher daher das jetzt eben die
booster impfungen so langsam greifen
aber dieser prozess wird wahrscheinlich
schleppend sein dieses entkoppeln der
krankheit schwere und die leute kommen
weiter auf die intensivstation und das
ist schrecklich also hängt alles davon
ab was in den nächsten tagen politisch
entschieden wird oder eben nicht danke
für das gespräch professor thorsten sehr
gern
wir haben das gespräch vor einer stunde
geführt wir waren in der redaktion
offengestanden betroffen davon wie ernst
unser gast über die gefahren sprach die
möglichen gefahren der neuen variante
und die ganz konkreten gefahren aus
abwarten der politik im augenblick auch
wegen der intensivstation jeder weiß wie
sehr sie die letzte beste chance bei
gefährlichen verläufen vieler
erkrankungen sind und sie stehen heute
schon am rand ihrer möglichkeiten
und das steht schon fest dass aus den
infektionen der letzten wochen
unausweichlich viele hundert vielleicht
tausende intensivpatienten entstehen
werden was das überhaupt heißt
behandlung auf intensivstation machte
ein lehrfilm der universität tübingen
klar ein junger arzt hat sich darauf
eingelassen sehr realistisch den
patienten zu spielen was man da sieht
hat aber nichts mit schauspielerei zu
tun das sind alles die wahren helden der
film zeigt die realität einer letzten
rettung christian von rechenberg mit
einer zusammenfassung entscheidender
augenblick
juden hämmerli kommt 30 jahre alt er
ringt nach luft das röntgenbild zeigt
warum
das milchige ist eine massive
lungenentzündung schwellungen und
flüssigkeit versperren der luft den weg
hämmerle droht zu ersticken seine organe
sind am ende ihrer kraft die zeit läuft
golde auf treatment letztendlich das
sind der ersten stunde so viel passiert
wie möglich um die organfunktionen zu
übernehmen und zu stabilisieren dieser
coup 19 fall ist simuliert der ablauf
ist echt ein lehrfilm der uniklinik
tübingen
auftritt kabel und schläuche es sind
sehr viele hämmerle wird sediert
schlafen gelegt was mit ihm passiert
soll er nicht miterleben etwa dass ihm
der anästhesist gleich einen schlauch
durch den mund in die luftröhre schiebt
hier über atmet ab jetzt eine maschine
für den patienten
beatmen zunächst mal um produktiv
natürlich das heißt wir versuchen die
lunge so weit zu schonen die es möglich
ist in dem wir eben die atemarbeit
übernehmen dustin platziert nun katheter
in venen und arterien 20 bis 30
zentimeter sind sie lang eingeschoben an
hals und leiste ultraschall hilft dabei
die katheter messen was tief im körper
vor sich geht reichen bis ins herz
hinein weitere sonden kommen hinzu etwa
in magen und blase
hämmerle wird mit medikamenten geflutet
sie ernähren ihnen führen ab steuern
herzschlag und blutdruck andere
verhindern gerinnsel bekämpfen bakterien
dazu kortison narkosemitteln flüssigkeit
die patienten
können nebenwirkungen erleiden durch
diese medikamentöse therapie aber sie
müssen das abwägen mit dem fakt dass die
patienten wahrscheinlich ohne diese
therapie nicht überleben würden ein
britischer arzt hat dieses bild gepostet
soviel medikamente bekommt ein qubit 19
patient auf intensiv pro tag keines
davon hilft gegen kuwait 19 uhr gegen
die symptome wir werden das so tief also
unterstützen das ganze ist eine
subjektive therapie die heilung muss
letztendlich vom patienten selbst auf
seinem körper kommen doch himmelskörper
ist zu schwach seine lunge leidet unter
der beatmung eine häufige komplikation
jetzt hilft nur noch die eco eine
maschine die das blut aus dem patienten
heraus pumpt und es mit sauerstoff
belädt außerhalb des körpers solange die
ekm läuft braucht der patient seine
lunge nicht mehr sie kann sich erholen
ein hochriskanter angriff
gleichzeitig ist es so dass diese
patienten durch den geringen
sauerstoffkonzentration relativ schnell
innerhalb von 12 stunden vor sterben
würden weil
sie einfach ihre organfunktionen nicht
mehr aufrecht halten können das müssen
sie gegeneinander abwägen natürlich
unterlaufen der ethno und bei vollem
bewusstsein beginnt hämmerles
physiotherapie im film nach einer stunde
in der realität dauert das alles wochen
im idealfall sieht die lunge dann wieder
so aus
normal hämmerle hat es also geschafft
einen schweren verlauf überlebt knapp
jeder zweite ähnlich erkrankte hat
dieses glück nicht und wer überlebt ist
noch lange nicht gesund
also das schwere lungen versagen macht
etwas mit den patienten dieser
umbauprozess in der lunge führt dazu
dass sie weniger leistungsfähig sind
eventuell ist vielleicht auch die
herzfunktion mit beeinträchtigt so dass
eine ganze reihe dieser patienten
hinterher auch sehr viel therapie
benötigen nur ein drittel aller
patienten kehrt in ein normales leben
zurück alle anderen müssen sich auf ein
neues ein eingeschränktes leben
einrichten
niemand der so was erlebt hat würde
jemals wieder seine sein leben einer
wette anvertrauen 90 minuten dauert
dieser film er soll jungen medizinern
zeigen was von ihnen erwartet wird die
nachrichten von gundula gause beginnen
im selben themenkomplex in der schweiz
bleibt es bei den beschlossenen corona
maßnahmen in einer volksabstimmung
sprachen sich über 62 prozent der
schweizer für das kogit 19 gesetz aus
grundlage für ein umstrittenes
zertifikat das impfung genesung oder
negativ tests belegt vor allem diesen
sogenannten kurve pass lehnen die gegner
der maßnahmen das zertifikat spalte die
schweiz und führe zu einem indirekten
impfzwang in einem weiteren referendum
befürworteten die schweizer reformen in
der pflege und bessere
arbeitsbedingungen in krankenhäusern und
heimen
gut zwei monate nach der wahl zum
berliner abgeordnetenhaus steht dort auf
landesebene die koalition von spd grünen
und linken die designierte regierende
bürgermeisterin gefahr erklärte der
koalitionsvertrag sei nach letzten
verhandlungen fertig morgen soll er
vorgestellt werden zugleich prüft eine
expertenkommission für den berliner
verfassungsgerichtshof die zahlreichen
wahl pannen am 26 september
im tarifstreit des öffentlichen dienstes
ist auch in der andauernden dritten
verhandlungsrunde noch immer keine
einigung in sicht man bewege sich
aufeinander zu liege aber noch weit
auseinander heißt es aus
verhandlungskreisen
auch von arbeitgeberseite liegt
inzwischen ein angebot vor die
gewerkschaft verdi fordert für die
800.000 beschäftigten fünf prozent mehr
gehalt mindestens aber 150 euro im monat
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg ist
weiterhin besorgt über den russischen
truppenaufmarsch nahe der grenze zur
ukraine im lettischen fernsehen forderte
er moskau zu zurückhaltung auf die usa
hatten kürzlich
geheimdienstinformationen veröffentlicht
denenzufolge russland im grenzgebiet zur
ukraine tausende soldaten zusammen zieht
sollten berg hat der ukraine mehr
bereits mehrfach die unterstützung der
nato zugesagt über
russland und auch die migrations krise
an der billa russisch polnischen grenze
wird ab dienstag auf einem nato treffen
in lettland beraten zur vorbereitung
haben stoltenberg und
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
gespräche mit litauens präsidentin aus
zeder geführt der warnte das
belarussische militär sei zunehmend in
die russischen streitkräfte integriert
von der leyen lobte litauen für den
umgang mit den migrations krise die eu
werde liter und lettland und polen 200
millionen euro zur grenzsicherung zur
verfügung stellen
das furchtbare unglück nahe dem
französischen ufer des ärmelkanals bei
dem am mittwoch 27 menschen ertranken 17
männer sieben frau drei kinder hat eine
schon lange akute krise ins bewusstsein
gerufen zehntausende vor allem aus den
konfliktgebieten des nahen ostens und
afghanistan sind unterwegs über belarus
und polen und deutschland richtung auch
großbritannien paris und london haben
die tage vier tage warnt nach dem
unglück damit zugebracht sich
gegenseitig die schuld an dieser
tragödie in die schuhe zu schieben heute
sollte ein treffen der eu-staaten am ort
des geschehens wenigstens eine
einheitliche europäische haltung
festlegen wo keine einfache lösung zur
erkenntnis jedenfalls keine die alle
gemeinsam politisch tragen wollen thomas
walde berichtet in der nähe von calais
wärmen sich am wochenende einige
migranten so gut es geht was die meisten
hier durchhalten lässt es die aussicht
bald zu versuchen den ärmelkanal zu
überqueren dass dabei vor kurzem 27
menschen starben schreckt sie nicht ab
[Musik]
ich habe vor nichts angst ich habe keine
furcht ertrinken wenn wir sterben es tut
mir leid dass sozusagen aber wir sind
schon gestorben niemand wird uns
irgendwo haben
tatsächlich haben viele vergeblich
versucht den ländern wie deutschland
asyl zu bekommen und nach dem break cit
ist die grenze zu den briten eine eu
außengrenze darum suchte frankreichs
innenminister europäische unterstützung
und lud kollegen nach calais ergebnis
ein flugzeug der europäischen
grenzsicherung cent uhr soll eingesetzt
werden
ab dem ersten dezember wird uns dieses
flugzeug von frontex sehr helfen im
einsatz gegen schlepperbanden und
überquerung versuche das ist ein schöner
erfolg
teilnehmer schlagen vor mit den briten
ein neues abkommen auszuhandeln
wir sind der auffassung dass es dringend
erforderlich ist das zwischen der
europäischen union und großbritannien
ein post dublin abkommen verhandelt wird
das zum inhalt hat das auch die frage
gegenseitiger rückführungen dabei
geregelt wird auch scherer der mann nun
mit den briten zusammenarbeiten dabei
hatte er deren innenministerin
ausgeladen nachdem der britische premier
öffentlich gefordert hatte dass
frankreich flüchtlinge zurücknehme die
die sicherungsanlagen in calais
überwinden die briten blieben am
wochenende bei ihren forderungen
was der premierminister vorgeschlagen
hat ist genau das was wir jetzt tun
müssen und ich hoffe die franzosen
nehmen das so hin und arbeiten mit und
großbritannien gilt bei migranten als
beliebt wegen arbeitsmöglichkeiten und
weil es nach dem break flüchtlinge nicht
einfach in die eu zurück schieben kann
24.000 haben es dieses jahr schon über
den kanal geschafft mehr als je zuvor
auch verstärkte überwachung schreckt sie
nicht ab
im moment ist überall polizei sie
sichern gerade die strände ab aber die
meisten hier warten bis alles wieder
normal ist und dann wollen sie nach
großbritannien
dort am anderen ufer in der nähe von
folkestone gedachten sie der wahl der
opfer des jüngsten unglücks wenn die
anderen staaten nicht gemeinsam eine
lösung finden werden die 27 toten nicht
die letzten gewesen sein
wir haben noch nachzutragen das
wichtigste von sporthallen in der
fußball-bundesliga hat rb leipzig am
abend gegen bayer leverkusen 1 zu 3
verloren leverkusen damit auf platz drei
der tabelle und im zweiten sonntagsspiel
hatte zuvor eintracht frankfurt union
berlin mit 2 1 besiegt die eintracht
rückt somit auf tabellenplatz zwölf form
zum wintersport die deutschen
skispringer legen einen top start in
diesem olympia winter hin beim weltcup
im finnischen ruka ist karl geiger bei
minus 16 grad auf platz zwei geflogen
und hat dabei auch das gelbe trikot des
gesamt führenden im weltcup verteidigt
auf platz drei landete markus
eisenbichler und auf eins der slowene
anze janitschek
bob fahrer francesco friedrich hat
seinen bisher makellosen triumphzug
fortgesetzt heute der vierte sieg im
vierten rennen der saison beim welt
platz ging ins programm der 31 jährige
mit seinem team im viererbob allen davon
schon gestern feierte er den sieg im
zweier auch bei den deutschen frauen
grund zum jubeln doppel erfolg im zweier
hier gewann laura nolte vor king khalid
im
tischtennis geschichte schreibt rekord
europameister timo boll bei der wm in
houston texas besiegte der 40-jährige
den us-amerikaner kanada und hat damit
bronze sicher und ist nun der bislang
älteste wm medaillengewinner seit der
ersten tischtennis wm 1926 im halbfinale
geht es für boll gegen den 19 jährigen
schweden möhre guard
zum ersten advent beginnen die beiden
großen christlichen hilfswerke
traditionell mit ihren bundesweiten
spendenaufrufen in münster eröffnete das
katholische hilfswerk adveniat mit einem
gottesdienst die weihnachtsaktion und
sammelt spenden diesmal insbesondere für
die arme stadt bevölkerung
lateinamerikas
die evangelische hilfsorganisation brot
für die welt stellt die
klimagerechtigkeit in den vordergrund
mit dem motto eine welt ein klima eine
zukunft
und am ende dieser sendewoche des
journals geht der blick nach vorne
[Musik]
sie reden nicht miteinander er
übereinander die erzfeinde iran und usa
beim thema atom sind die fronten frostig
das soll sich am montag ändern
diplomaten aus fünf staaten darunter
auch deutschland haben gespräche in wien
vermittelt nach monaten funkstille
fraglich ob ein durchbruch gelingt
weil die regierung in der korona krise
teilweise harte beschränkungen
durchsetzen musste stapeln sich beim
bundesverfassungsgericht die beschwerden
darüber es sind rund 300 was dürfte der
start im lockdown was nicht am dienstag
gibt es die ersten antworten
bisher hatten sie sich nur einzeln
präsentiert nun gibt es das erste
gemeinsame sogenannte townhall meeting
von mehr zu rücken und braun die
bewerber um den vorsitz der cdu stellen
sich ihrer partei und allerlei fragen
wer schlägt sich im dreikampf am besten
und mit welchen mitteln eine erste
tendenz am mittwoch
für mich soll's rote rosen regnen das
spielt die bundeswehr am donnerstag für
angela merkel beim großen zapfenstreich
ehrung und abschied nach 16 jahren
kanzlerin der hof ihres amtssitzes hätte
merkel für die zeremonie genügt doch
fackelträger musikkorps und ehrengäste
brauchen platz den bietet das
verteidigungsministerium stimmungsvolle
momente
inklusive
das wetter in dieser neuen woche bringt
ein bisschen schnee und kräftigen wind
die sonne zeigt sich morgen nur im
nordwesten sonst ist es nasskalt mit
regen und schneeschauern teils mit
glätte bei minus drei grad im allgäu bis
plus sechs grad an der nordsee am
dienstag fällt im süden viel schnee
später wie in der mitte auch regeln
dabei ist es teils stürmisch auch der
mittwoch wird windig und nass aber mit
vier bis elf grad mild der donnerstag
wieder kälter
morgen übernahm übernehmen christian
sievers und kaiser richter diese plätze
und bringen ihnen dann den überblick
über das tagesgeschehen wir wünschen
allen eine gute woche bis bald ist für
ein amt
[Musik]